he slit off my clothes from the trousers
all the way to the back
up until there's a top and i could feel
that
that cold steel against my skin they
shaved my hair off shake my beard off
laughed at it they paraded me naked
after they shackled me
in front of soldiers taking photographs
and then after that they put on the
infamous orange
[Music]
jumpsuit
[Music]
[Music]
so
where were you detained i was with my
wife and children
yeah we'd been working on a project to
build a school in afghanistan
when the u.s led invasion began in 2001
so we evacuated under american bombs
and made it to pakistan which is where
my family originated from anyway
and we took up residence there yeah i
was there for a couple of months
there's a knock on the door i opened the
door
and there's a bunch of people standing
there none of them in uniform
one of them pulls out a gun pushes it to
my head
i know my family my wife and kids are in
the other rooms
and i tell them please leave them alone
the group of people then surround me
they push me onto the onto my knees and
then
tie my hands behind my back push me into
the prone position
shackle my legs put a hood over my head
at this point i don't know who these
people are i don't know whether they're
bandits yeah armed robbers somebody
lifts
my hood there's two guys dressed
as pakistanis but they're not pakistanis
they're white
americans and they say you can either
answer our questions here
or you can answer them in guantanamo bay
so i was detained
because this was the war on terror and
they could detain anybody they wanted to
yeah
okay tell us about the day you were
detained
um yes it was actually quite an
interesting day
if you don't have the right
status to live in the uk you have to go
and sign in with the home office to tell
them that oh
i'm still in the country but on this
fateful day i
i thought i was going to go in and come
out as usual
and i went in and i never came back out
until
about three months later and you were
detained and i was detained
straight away and police stationed in
prison um detention center
then that's where they take people
whilst they
process their deportation i myself
didn't know where i was i didn't know if
i was safe i didn't know
what was going on i didn't know when i
was going to get released
it was just i was left in the dark and
did you know where they were they wanted
to deport you to did you have an idea
which country they wanted yes nigeria
where i originally came from when i was
13.
what were the conditions like where you
were detained
the conditions were terrible it's filled
with
rats rodents absolutely you see them
running around oh absolutely they come
through under the door come into your
room you're in this
detention center with a lot of other
people you know there are people who
have serious mental um challenges and
they get violent once they lock that
cell it's you can't
they don't open it until the morning so
anything can happen
so every day you live life on the edge
with fear anxiety
um depression you just sometimes just
wake up and just i just want to end it
all
because i don't know what to do that's
how bad it was that's how bad it was yes
did you have in your mind like if if
they were
the day may come where they're going to
literally grab you and stick you onto a
plane absolutely
it's always pla that's that's it it's a
mental uh
torture because you don't know what when
that day will come
before the end of that day you're back
to
where you came from it's a place you
haven't seen since you were
yes absolutely what were your condition
like
probably the worst conditions i came
across was in when i was held in a place
called kandahar
and we were in communal cells that have
been makeshipped
uh built by the military they gave us a
bucket like i mean literally a metal
bucket to use as a toilet
between 12 of us probably the worst
abuse i've encountered of other
prisoners
it was in bagram in around february 2002
yeah they bought a prisoner
uh to the front of the cell and this was
like a communal cell that says about 12
of us
but this prisoner started shouting in
pashtu which is a language i don't speak
spoken in afghanistan but he was clearly
complaining
yeah they put this particular individual
at the front and they tied his hands
to the top of the door yeah and left him
like this kind of suspended
with a hood over his head and
they left him like this for hours and
then days they would
unshackle him just to give him let him
go to the toilet or to to eat
otherwise he's always shuffled up um
then one day
his head just dropped and they opened
the door and the first thing they did
the soldiers is to start punching him
like in the ribs to see if he's
pretending
yeah and then they unshackled him and
then carried him off upstairs i didn't
know what happened at the time but there
was a rumor that he's dead
you know later they did a film i think
called the taxi to the dark side it got
the oscar for best documentary was about
the death of this
this taxi driver he was a taxi driver
and he was innocent
wow that's crazy
how did it feel to go from free to
detained so quickly
you start asking questions about who you
are
you start to doubt everything that you
know to be true
it's like a nightmare my first
interrogation was in this tent
in the middle of the kandahar desert
they
threw me onto the floor he slit off my
clothes
from the trousers all the way to the
back up until the top
and i could feel that that cold steel
against my skin
they shaved my hair off shake my beard
off laughed at it
bringing dogs to bark salivate
and then they paraded me naked after
they shackled me
in front of soldiers taking photographs
being asked ridiculous questions and
then after that they put on the
infamous orange jumpsuit
but yeah all of that's designed to
terrify you it's not natural
for somebody to be detained and
imprisoned that's not a natural state of
any human being
we are social animals we don't
naturally thrive in in solitary
confinement absolutely
we interact with people we we talk we
walk we love we hate we do all of those
things as
normal people in a in a free society
literally in the click of a finger all
of that can be taken
what was the hardest thing about your
detainment you know hardest thing has to
be being away from my family
i had three children um the eldest who
at the time was six
and then they went down into you know
there was a four-year-old and
an um and a two-year-old
and then after i was taken to custody i
had my youngest
child born so i never saw him
until he was three years old first time
i ever saw him in his life was when he
was three years old
the knowledge that your children are
growing up without you
it was probably more than i could handle
so the only way i could deal with that
was cut myself off just don't
tell yourself you're a father letters
would come every now and then
from my kids and they would redact
black out wow most of what she's written
except for at the end i love you dad
that broke the dam
because that reminded me that i have
children
i was pacing up in myself three steps
forward three steps back
and i just lost i had a panic attack
started punching kicking screaming
swearing at the soldiers
just going mad doing things that i
normally would never do
and the worst psychological torture i
think both of us could understand this
is that you don't know when this is
going to end there are times when if
somebody's got a
hearing date for a court a bill for
example we tell them
listen you're going to the school we
don't we don't want you back here
you're going don't come back and it's a
practice that we do
we kind of just give out some of the
things we have maybe the tops the
shirts the socks just give them to other
people
in the hopes that we're not going to
come back and need that stuff we're not
going to need that stuff
it happened to me so i had a bill
hearing um
i was thought i'm not going to come back
here i was happy giving out
staff to people went to court and if
my family was there my relatives were
there so i was
everyone was hoping that oh yeah it's
coming home of us and
my bill got refused just picked me off
straight
and straight back into the van and
that was it they didn't give me a chance
to say bye didn't give me a chance to
you know not even a hug no nothing
nothing just it was a very it was
the worst um moment of my life actually
um being refused that bill when i know
that i have
every right to be free because i haven't
committed anything
they they make you feel like
insignificant just come in
to terms that i'm actually
powerless
how were you released so randomly an
unknown number called and said oh
um if you were to release you today
where are you going to go
and literally at that moment my head
went blank my brain went blank i was
like
wait wait wait was my address was my
address for my address
i couldn't remember my address um so i
told him to give me a minute to just
calm down and just recollect and um
so i gave him my release address and
before that evening i was out of there
it was a surreal moment when those gates
opened and i walked out i looked back i
was like wow
i couldn't believe i was like wait i'm
actually out yeah
how about yours i remember that there
was a u.s
military officer came to my cell soldier
component i've been there for three
years
and she says 558 we are dec we have
decided to release you to the custody of
the british government
and you'll be going home i thought you
lying cow
um i didn't want to believe her but sure
enough they sent a um
a detail of soldiers they shackled me up
and the americans in the
haste to to you know hand this over
whatever
they forgot the keys to the padlocks
they came over with a massive pair of
wire cutters
and they had to snap off the chains they
sat us down
um and then offered me chocolates
crisps and importantly the newspapers
and on the front of the newspapers
including i have to say the sun
you had my picture and a bunch of other
people oh wow this is
this is bad yeah i'm on the front page
of the sun wow
well i said you know you you can never
understand or appreciate freedom unless
it's been taken away from you yeah
i didn't know that indefinite detention
happens in britain i didn't know
yeah and britain is the land of
and america's the land of laws justice
habeas corpus
magna carta all of that stuff yeah no
man shall be detained yeah without
a being judged by a jury of their peers
yeah all of that
is a load of nonsense when it comes to
these places the lawyers who represented
me
on that also dealt with cases like yours
and i came across more than i can i can
recount
yeah and started to realize that
detention without trial
in britain is a massive thing as a long
history
i didn't come out broken i came out
stronger you know i came out
with the with the will and the zeal that
i'm going to
do something about this i want to do
something about this
for the people that are still in there
right now i feel
a sense of um fight
like i need to fight for them i i can
forgive for what was done to me i can't
forgive for what's being done to people
right now yes i don't have the right to
do that
i think the day or the day or the day
after i came back
i asked my wife for the keys to to a car
i jumped into the car
and i'm gonna i'm gonna experience the
ultimate freedom
which is driving down the motorway with
the windows down feeling the wind in my
hair
and when i did that that was just like
the ultimate sense of
free i could never have done this in
content
so it's been been amazing talking to you
absolutely on your team
pleasure thank you thank you very much
someone catches wind of it jesus christ
like they'll be like hey fishing or ice
cake
fish boy talking to a girl online and
then finding out that
i'm fishing a rice cake and then just
never speaking to me again
you don't plant your fish i'm not on
plenty of fish no i've not tried that
one
take your fish and wife's tapes oh no
he's shredding me